I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT,
BUT THAT WAS WHAT THEY WERE
INFORMED TO DO ON BOARD THE
SHIP.
ROUGH DAY ON WALL STREET.
OIL PRICES PLUMMETING, STOCKS
KEEP FALLING AS A VIRUS
CONTINUES TO SPREAD.
THERE IS A LIFE LOOK AT THE DOW.
WE WERE UP MORE THAN THAT
EARLIER, BRINGING IN BULLS AND
BEARS, FOX BUSINESS NETWORK,
HELLO TO YOU, MY FRIEND.
>> ONLY OFF 1800 POINTS.
>> Bill: YOU SAID 100 MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE SOME PORTION OF
MONEY INVESTED IN THE MARKET.
>> MOST PEOPLE KNOW IT AS A
401(K), IRA, MORE MINING IS
ACTUALLY AN INDIVIDUAL
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS,
$10 TRILLION VERSUS ABOUT
$5.5 TRILLION, BUT AMERICANS ARE
INVESTED IN THIS ECONOMY.
AND A LOT OF THEM ARE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THE
STOCK MARKET.
THEY LOOK AT IT RIGHT NOW
TUMBLING, BY THE WAY, THIS IS AN
ANNIVERSARY.
MARCH 9TH, 2009, 11 YEARS AGO
TODAY WAS THE BEGINNING OF THE
BULL MARKET.
THAT WAS THE LOW POINT DURING
THE FINANCIAL CRISIS.
WE HAVE COME UP EVERY YEAR
SINCE, THIS DAY TODAY,
IRONICALLY ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE BULL MARKET MIGHT BE THE END
OF THE BULL MARKET, ONLY 350
POINTS AWAY FROM IT IF IT
CONTINUES TO GO DOWN FROM A 20%
CORRECTION, WHICH IS CONSIDERED
A BEGINNING OF A BEAR MARKET.
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED, BUT THEY
SHOULD NOT TAKE THEIR MONEY OUT
OF THEIR ACCOUNTS RIGHT NOW IF
WHAT THEY HAVE AS AN IRA OR
401(K).
I WILL TELL YOU WHY, BECAUSE
BASICALLY IT IS THE LAST BIT OF
STOCK THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
RETIREMENT ACCOUNT TO THAT YOU
REACH.
TIME IS YOUR FRIEND.
IF YOU ARE HOLDING STOCKS OVER A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME, NO BETTER
ASSET THAT DOES BETTER THAN THE
STOCK MARKET.
CONSIDERING IT IS THE LAST THING
THAT YOU TOUCH.
IF YOU ARE ALREADY DIPPING INTO
IT, IT IS TOO LATE.
IF YOU HAVE A FEW YEARS BEFORE
YOU BEGIN TO DIP IN, LEAVE IT
THERE AND UNTOUCHED.
OVER TIME IT ALWAYS IMPROVES.
I’M TALKING ABOUT A FIVE YEAR
TREND, TENURE TREND, DEFINITELY.
EVEN A FIVE YEAR TREND IS YOUR
FRIEND.
AND IT MAY WELL BE THAT THIS IS
ONLY A SIX MONTH OR ONE YEAR
DOWN MARKET IF WE ENTER INTO
BEAR TERRITORY.
EVERY TIME WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
ONE OF THE VIRUSES BEFORE AFTER
SIX MONTHS, WE COME OUT AND THE
STOCK MARKET IS AHEAD.
>> Bill: IT IS EXCELLENT
ADVICE YOU ARE GIVING HERE,
BASICALLY SAYING, DON’T PANIC.
>> DON’T PANIC.
>> Bill: IT IS A HARD THING TO
DO WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR
RETIREMENT MONEY AND YOUR
TIMELINE.
>> THE WORST MISTAKES ARE MADE
WHEN PEOPLE DO SOMETHING WITH
THEIR STOCKS ON THE BASIS OF A
PANIC.
BUY OR SELL.
YOU DON’T DO EITHER THING IF YOU
FEEL PANICKY, THEN JUST TURN OFF
THE CHANNEL AND WAIT.
AS LONG AS YOU CAN AFFORD TO
WAIT FOR SIX MONTHS-A YEAR, YOU
WILL BE OKAY.
>> Bill: A COUPLE OF CONCERNS,
YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH
A VIRUS, MAYBE IT IS WHAT WE
THINK THAT MAYBE IT IS NOT.
THE OTHER IS THE WORLD ECONOMY,
SLOWING DOWN, YOU CAN FORECAST
THAT.
AND WHAT I SAW FROM ISRAEL WAS
STUNNING TO ME.
THEY ARE SAYING ANYONE WHO
TRAVELS INTO THE COUNTRY OF
ISRAEL WILL GO INTO A 14-DAY
QUARANTINE.
EVERYONE.
IF OTHER COUNTRY START DOING
THAT, THERE IS A PILE ON EFFECT
OF THE GLOBAL ECONOMY GOING
SLOWER.
>> THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO YOU
DO BUSINESS?
WE WENT AFTER THIS 9/11, WHEN WE
ENCOUNTER WHAT WE HAVE NOT IN
PERSON.
THAT’S WHEN TELECONFERENCING
TOOK OFF LIKE WILDFIRE.
NOW EVEN MORE SO.
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF STUFF THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE THEREFORE IF, IN
FACT, WE HAVE QUARANTINES OF
FACTORIES AND OFFICE BUILDINGS.
EVEN THIS OFFICE BUILDING.
WHO KNOWS.
WE MAY BE QUARANTINED A YEAR.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS IN AMERICA IF, IN FACT,
TO THIS QUARANTINE GOES OFFICE
WIDE AND FACTORY WIDE AND
EVERYTHING.
I DON’T THINK WE WILL GO THERE,
BUT IF THAT HAPPENS, THE
ECONOMY, THE WORLD ECONOMY WILL
TAKE A HIT.
IN THE EUROPEANS WERE CLOSE TO
RECESSION BEFORE THE VIRUS
CHAOS, MUCH CLOSER TO ONE NOW.
>> Bill: TELLING THE GUYS IN
STUDIO, THAT I WENT TO AN NBA
GAME IN MADISON SQUARE GARDEN ON
FRIDAY NIGHT AND NOTHING
HAPPENED.
>> I JUST CAME BACK FROM MIAMI,
BILL, THE PLANE WAS FULL, AND
NOBODY CARED.
PARTICULARLY PLANES MAY BE ONE
OF THE SAFEST PLACES, BECAUSE
EVERYBODY IS WASHING DOWN EVERY
INCH.